en la noche de gaza suenan explosiones
las fuerzas armadas israelíes acaban de
efectuar ataques aéreos contra el
enclave palestino según la agencia de
prensa de jamás dos lugares del
territorio fueron blanco del ejército
israelí
[Música]
durante todo el día el estado hebreo ha
sido blanco de misiles disparados desde
raza en reacción a la muerte de Jaden el
martes por la mañana la administración
penitenciaria israelí anunció la muerte
de esta figura de la yihad islámica que
llevaba tres meses en huelga de hambre
para protestar contra su detención
Aunque la mayoría de los cohetes cayeron
en terrenos baldíos dos de ellos
alcanzaron la ciudad desde erot en el
sur de Israel
mi esposa me llamó para decirme que un
cohete cazam cayó en nuestro jardín
gracias a Dios no hubo víctimas Nadie
estaba en el jardín los niños estaban a
salvo para muchos palestinos
de la resistencia su muerte provocó una
ola de ira en gaza pero también encies
Jordania para el Primer Ministro
palestino se trata de un crimen
perpetrado por Israel
consideramos que se trata de un
asesinato intencionado debido al rechazo
de su petición de liberación a la
negligencia médica y a que continuaba
detenido en su celda a pesar de la
gravedad de su estado
el intercambio de disparos hace tener
una nueva escalada en la región el
pasado agosto tres días de
enfrentamientos entre ambas partes
causaron la muerte de 49 palestinos
entre ellos al menos 19 niños según la o